are you catching the view I don't know
what the camera we got the yeah beyond
thinkable young imaginable happen look
at the beautiful scenic view huh so our
first time riding the horse delivering
the purpose of life to the world
he would continue on and a horse got
thrown off think he should go faster he
literally did a jiu jitsu roles as he
came halfway it's clean law work but to
the forest here we're riding for about
half an hour
horses are taking a break we're about to
get back up on the road here in the part
of Europe the balkans in Bosnia what Han
are you doing
all right guys you ready let's go back
at it again home did it not you would
think that the Sahaba those men at that
great heroes at that time we're out
there who cared for humanity so they got
there went out there sharing the purpose
of life was humanity magic they didn't
have planes trains and automobiles but
they were out there for imagine weeks
months doing the Dawa on horseback
providing the Sun what about us what
excuse do we have huh got our
comfortable cars
that's right brother imagine you have to
have you have to be out there on
horseback delivering the message
delivering the purpose huh I'm doing
laughs look at this view look at this
view beautiful imagine the great Giants
of the Dean Oh but even a fee who took
this message all the way to modern-day
Tunisia Algeria to North Africa and it's
narrated that he got up into the today
edge of the ocean the sea and he pulled
the reins on his horse he pulled the
reins on his horse look at that
and he said Allah but God is the
greatest
by Allah if this see this ocean this
water wasn't here to prevent me from and
I knew that there was people on the
other side I would continue delivering
this message this Dean the Dean of Jesus
of Moses of Abraham the way of life of
all the messengers delivering the
purpose of life to the world
he would continue on on horseback riding
for months it's clean Allahu Akbar
Allahu Akbar god is the greatest for our
brothers and sisters on humanity it's
not a war crap
without be
[Music]
you talk about adventure huh you didn't
expect we did not expect to be riding
deep in the forest deep uphill downhill
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah I got it what do you say Oh
[Music]
who's the greatest Allah God Almighty
the greatest
a solo that's me too
Wow what I did finish it Oh father I'm
gonna cry
that's good baby good watch yourself
well you catching this
yeah look at the beautiful scenic view
huh it's our first time riding the horse
[Music]
I did wait no but I'd like first got it
ma'am look at this are you catching the
view I don't know what the camera we got
the view yeah this is like it's fake but
it's beautiful it's real cool first time
writing this is like you don't get on
the dial get out of range sometime maybe
okay we got a steep one here bismillah
here come on Ibrahim law Oh crud and Hum
didn't I
you
huh yeah yeah we're like how many
thousands of feet up in the air base at
the top of the mountain so we're already
going downhill on the mountain and this
is mines and Eddie's first time going
and they said it takes about you know a
handful of training sessions like a
month of going through these things to
actually go out there and do it
but he and our first day never read a
horse in our life he gave us a chance to
ride a horse
and we went up the mountains curves
everything we're learning as we go like
basically guys like when you go up pull
up when you're going down to he'll pull
back so we're all learning right and as
we're going down I was kind of scared I
want to go down but they convinced me to
go down hill and as we're going downhill
Eddie's going downhill to and from what
I remember what I heard the guy was
yelling and as the guy was yelling I
guess Eddie's horse got scared and his
horse got thrown off thinking should go
faster and Eddie was recording so he
wasn't holding like he's supposed to
with two hands and I guess he lost
control and when I turned her to the
left all I saw Eddie he literally did a
digital role so as he came halfway I
fought I saw it just Eddie from like
halfway out a horse he rolled over and
like tumbled and uh thank God nothing
happened
I would actually thought I was scared
that the horse was gonna like run over
him or kick him or something but the
horse kept on going forward and and
we've got a good view out of it it was
beautiful thank God to the Almighty for
giving us a chance to see the beautiful
view guys all right hum did it loud we
got back we're ready for least minimum
two hours or more deep up into there to
the mountain and then the unthinkable
young imaginable happened the worst
nightmare and a horse happened you dread
falling off and that's what happened I
fell off the lesson there is you put
that with life we're gonna fall you got
to get right back on I got right back on
the horse and then we wrote for another
one hour another hour so lesson learned
whatever challenges you go to our life
just like to falling off that horse you
get right back on you got to get right
back on on that journey of life put your
trust in your maker in your Creator you
never give up keep a little forward to
watching the beach jumping bombing